SHYAMAL MEHTA: TechJini is
a multinational company.
And the reason
TechJini exists is
to enable businesses to
leverage emerging technologies
to solve their problems.
AMIT RANA: The most
important thing
is to keep on learning
new technology, you know?
Be ready for what is
going to come next.
So we heard about Google
Developers Agency program
from Android
company [INAUDIBLE].
We were pretty excited
to be part of it,
because it opens a channel to
directly interact with Google
engineers.
We have been developing for
Android since 2008, when
the first version came out.
We were sure that they'd
have a lot of input--
we can give it back.
And there were a lot
of learning which
we can take from the program.
So give it no second thought.
SHYAMAL MEHTA: There was
certain criteria for us
to fulfill to become a certified
Google Developers Agency.
Luckily, we were able to fulfill
those because of our work
and because of our
association with Google
for almost a year before
the certification actually
happened.
DIVYARANI S: I was
looking at TechJini,
and I used to rely on
my junior developers.
I took [? a ?] [? maternity ?]
[? leave, ?] and my company
joined the Google
Developers Agency program.
After a year when I
came back, everything
was different in a great way.
I took my junior
developers' help
to train me on
those technologies.
YOGESHWAR RAO:
Pepperfry.com is India's
leading financial retailer.
When we first started
working with them,
they had a huge web presence.
But they did not have
any mobile presence.
SPEAKER 1: The challenge
with the Pepperfry app
was that it's a very
visually heavy application.
So we worked hand-in-hand
with the Google team
to ensure that we give
a great user experience,
whether they are on a fast
4G network or a 2G network.
YOGESHWAR RAO: Even after
following the best practices,
we would hit a
performance roadblock.
On those instances, we reached
out to the agency program,
making sure that we are
rendering the images
in the highest quality possible
without affecting the user's
ability to infinitely scroll
through a lot of images.
There were suggestions around
the data binding feature,
along with libraries
such as glide.
Overall when we made the switch
from Eclipse and [INAUDIBLE]
to Android Studio, coupled
with all these inputs
from the agency
program, I think it
helped us achieve really
fast development life cycles.
SHYAMAL MEHTA: The Google
Developers Agency program
has been beneficial to
us in multiple ways.
And I think its been
a great association
to be able to qualify for
the certification criteria.
AMIT RANA: It validates all
the good work we are doing.
And it helps us make sure
we are always on the edge.